I will not be lectured about sexism and  misogyny by this man I will not miss  ogyny by this man not now not ever the  leader of the Opposition says that  people who hold sexist views and who are  misogynist are not appropriate for high  office well I hope the leader of the  Opposition has got a piece of paper and  he is writing out his resignation  because if he wants to know what  misogyny looks like in modern Australia  he doesn't need a motion in the House of  Representatives  he needs a mirror that's what he I was  offended when the leader of the  Opposition went outside in the front of  Parliament and stood next to a sign that  said teach the weak I was offended when  the leader of the Opposition makes to a  sign that describe me as a man's [ __ ] I  was offended by those things misogyny  sexism every day from this labour of the  opposition